they know the injustice of asking these
holders very often young people who have
saved hard and made sacrifices to get
their first steps on the housing ladder
to pay money they don't have to fix a
problem they didn't cause
all while the firms that made a profit
on those developments sit on their hands
so we'll take action to end the scandal
and protect leaseholders we will scrap
the proposal for loans and long-term
debt for medium rise leaseholders i can
confirm today to the house that no
leaseholder living in a building above
11 meters will ever face any costs for
fixing dangerous cladding and
working with members of both houses we
will pursue statutory protection for
leaseholders and nothing will be off the
table
as part of this we'll introduce
immediate amendments to the building
safety bill to extend the right of
leaseholders to challenge those who
cause defects in premises up to 30 years
retrospectively and we will also take
further action immediately we'll provide
an additional 27 million pounds to fund
more fire alarms so we can end the
dreadful misuse of waking watches we
will change grant funding guidance so
that shared owners affected by this
crisis can more easily sublet their
properties and encourage lenders and
landlords to approve subletting
arrangements and in the period before
long-term arrangements have put in place
i will work with colleagues across
government to make police holders are
protected from forfeiture and eviction
because of historic costs